i think it might be
useful for us to uh get some advice from
you
yeah all right because you've
accomplished for for
the the journey of a martial artist
first
if you've accomplished some of the
greatest accolades there is in the sport
if
somebody who's starting out now or like
early on in their journey
what advice would you give on how to
become
a martial artist a catch wrestler
fighter
uh well i mean really what it comes down
to is do it because you love it
do it for that reason and that reason
alone
most people that get into this and
attempt to make
any sort of professional inroads with it
you are
not going to be the world champion uh
you probably will never even fight for a
belt
and you're probably not going to net
make money at this
so don't do it for those reasons do it
for the reason of the passion
do it for the reason to be the absolute
best that you can be
whatever that ends up being you might at
best only be
mediocre but you won't even be mediocre
if you don't do it like you really mean
it
so compassion look where's the kernel of
the passion
would you say is it in the learning
process itself the improvement
i think it really depends on the person
right i mean there's some people that
really love
the the the fact of they feel like
they're growing
right so built power you know you're
growing growing stronger growing better
um you know the idea of of
eliminating weakness so
twitch i'll quickly define weaknesses as
like things that weaken you not like
being physically weak
sure you could call that weakness but
maybe you're not meant to be a super
strong guy
but choosing to be weak is
really a different story other than just
like we're all
uh deficient in some way or another so
that's neither here nor there it's a
matter of what you decide to do with it
and that's an infinite strength and
weakness at least the way i look at it
like strength is choosing
regardless of the difficulty to make
improvements to
strength is even choosing to acknowledge
that you you do lack
and accept it and then make a decision
what to do with it um yeah but there's
also
there's a bunch of stuff that just like
you said it's what you're drawn to
there's an honesty to just grappling
that it seems more real than anything
else you can do
sure and that's the that's where the
passion of love can come yeah i mean
it's
being in an environment hopefully that
is as true as possible
uh would be would be a a starter so it's
hard to be
a a [ __ ] person when you're
literally trying to tear each other's
arms off yeah you know you really sort
of see who somebody is
i also feel like you really really get
to see somebody who there are a couple
instances where you really see who
people are
uh on the mats and in the bedroom so
[Laughter]
even the aspect of self
betterment uh
growth along a path i mean hell that's
part of the
the the divisive capture for
martial arts as a business give you a
belt
put a stripe on your belt each each of
these iterations cost 20 bucks
so there's a benefit to that too i i
really enjoyed
the progression of belts sure is it i'm
you know a bit of his ocd or whatever
but you're enjoying
recognition your your growth when you
feel when you're made to feel when i
think
genuinely you do earn it yeah i agree i
process
i agree i actually makes complete sense
to me it just it's
anything that is is has a goodness in
its purity can also have
a detriment in its perversion so
you